hi and welcome to another exciting
edition of instant trailer reviews today
we're looking at the teaser trailer for
Jupiter ascending the latest work from
the wachowski siblings formerly known as
the Wachowski brothers yeah I'm David
and I'm Jas so here we go alright good
sign this is Chicago at Chicago shocking
yeah so what we have here is Sean Bean
giving the opening yes from Game of
Thrones Ned Stark um but this time he's
not Ned Stark he's someone else's of
course now we don't know what this is
doing why he has a tattoo on his neck
and it's a Channing Tatum looking kind
of like Spock with some sort of Spock
yeah absolutely what is that like a 25
right to 15 or 20 15 we don't know it's
very mysterious and that appeals to us
right absolutely we got Ned Stark over
here now Jess what do you know about the
plot of this movie all i know is that
mila kunis is a Russian immigrant of
sorts I guess she's come to Chicago and
she is I guess the human race is
descending and this sci-fi dystopia and
Channing Tatum has come to save her
because her life is in danger
unbeknownst to her
so I guess she gets kidnapped here by
some scientists they have to confirm
that it's her and they go obviously
she's important I know this is pretty
cool it's livery straight at Star Trek
though I mean this is like a spot guy
shooting laser beams on it was a handgun
Channing Tatum this isn't that we've
never seen Channing like this before
have we and he looks kind of like
Benedict Cumberbatch actually from the
latest static film with with ready
trench coat yeah he's got this sort of
like Errol Flynn goatee of course the
matrix trilogy we have to sell that this
is actually a really cool shot how often
you actually see people getting beamed
up anymore yeah that was like in 1950s
kind of sci-fi thing I know it's like
how come it didn't say from the creators
of cloud atlas trui because this
actually is a lot like Cloud Atlas but
of course the matrix is more popular a
Mila Kunis doesn't really done sci-fi it
before Ashley she's done a lot of
comedies she voices for Family Guy yeah
she did the book of eli which was like
another no we don't we don't really know
what the planet this is doing it looks
like it's built together some sort of
Elysium um sort of like what was the
place in Elysium it was Alisa yeah
Elysium ok
ok I creature yeah this little interval
almost a little splice light you
remember that film yeah yeah so I don't
know what's going on there oh this is
cool this reminds me a lot of Thor of
Thor though look we have chandeliers in
the spaceship that is very and then this
cool ship and I give like gargoyles and
statues bringing that kind of like space
odyssey or like space opera feel ya the
witch house keys are definitely known
for going all out with the visuals as
this
part of a very large industry
I just feel so much like the cop Cloud
Atlas trailer I think this is a great
shot for them to throw it in the trailer
though it's like a transformers Robots
so far we're seeing a lot of different
things between elements of Game of
Thrones and transformers and Thor and
Star Wars and matrix I mean they're
throwing in as many genres as they can
get something they really did with Cloud
Atlas is they explored all these
different genres and it had a sci-fi
portion oh if you go back to hear this
is eddie redmayne who you might
recognize home playlist yeah yeah so he
was also in Black Death the horror film
of sean bean actually so it's cool that
they're working together again doesn't
this feel gay blade runner ish ya know
there's there's all sorts there's gonna
be a lot of a cool movie all matches i
think in this she's still with the
beaming i just all beaming each other in
this whole movie and there's this what
is this like this is a gargoyle looks
like a cool set piece of the movie I'm
back look he's flying on escape like
skate like rollerskating goblin right do
you get a little bit he's got like a
green Madrid um should you look closely
look see she's wearing sneakers that can
like yeah I mean there's so much to
dissect here I mean we're just going
right so we've learned that her name is
Jupiter right
we have another it looks just like Thor
so Jupiter sending by the way chomsky's
jazz what do you think you can see this
movie absolutely i'm going to see
anything that which house keys do cloud
atlas was hit or miss for me because it
was so much of a just a jumbling of
genres and moods but i think this you
know they're sticking to one thing and i
think it's what they do best and that's
sci-fi so what'd you think of the trail
do you think the trailer sells what this
movie is i think it's very for me it's
very vague what the plot is absolutely
all I know right now there's some cool
Thor star wars kind of stuff is from the
people who brought you the matrix
there's a lot of cool flying and jumping
and bullet time probably and they sort
we certainly see a great cast I think
the trailer does a great job of showing
that and it definitely it it's almost
more of a teaser what do you feel like
you sort of have these vague images with
nothing really putting any story
together any theme I don't release as I
prefer that though because yeah the
trend with trailers these days is to
give away everything and I'm just like
I'm glad that there's a lot left yeah
this trailer definitely shows who hero
is who the villain is what world are in
and sometimes it's a trailer that's all
it needs to show um and the set design
is absolutely fantastic definitely so we
know there's gonna be tons of CGI and
tons of fighting what else we learn from
this tree ojs anything else that's
that's the gist I guess that's all we
need because it's a trailer and that's
cool alright well expand your universe
next summer so thanks for joining us for
another instant trailer review i'm jes
and I'm David